[拍手]
醤油の私販売をしている
55紹介すると前でも実家な醤油なのだけど教えているんですけれども全く違う業界
からこの世界に飛び込んでき
大学を卒業して再就職したのは精密機器のお願いでした
そこで3年間栄養食としての仕事をさせていただいている
で対処しました
その時に伝統産業がちー作業なんかその他ゲームで何かをしたいなんていうのは思って
いたんですけれども具体的な何をしようかっていうのは何も考えずに仕事を辞めて
しまったって受けいただけました
それが今から10年くらい前ことです
いざ伝統産業ちー作業内容しようかなーっていう風に考えておいたんですけれども
なかなかどうしようかなと思っているとき
ただそのときに私一つ幸運だったとか
対策をしたいったのに結婚しに書いています
ありません
で降格候補がつ分お仕事を辞めてしまいますので
二人して無職の状態でやる式を受けること
でまぁ伝統産業いうぐらいですから私は着物を着て
式をしようと
いうのは持田つまり提案したところちょっと待ってよっ
私はウェディングドレスが着たい
バージンロードが着たい
あなた私の夢を何だと思っている
海は力になる人は絶対だめだなぁと思いまして者といえ無感情を見に行こっ
いうことで京都仕事も神社に行きました
中を一通りらんないいただいてで最後にその
さこちゃんとの方がここは世界遺産に登録されてい
これから数十年数百年おそらくこの地にこの場所はあり続けると思いますのが何か心に
引っかかってくれたみたいで
オイラ達で違うので式を挙げることができました
次に居るのが清峰力を本体感ですん
であの友人たちのリサーチをしたところを少し市下新本旅行の定番として要録画でき
ます
きたんは1色です予算は少しリッチに100万円という話をちらほら聞いたのでまた
集まってきます
貧乏旅行で予算100万円だったら何日ぐらい優雅で
松葉もだいぶさせてくれたような好きにしてください
ということで3ヶ月間日本の貧乏旅行をすることができます
夜の宅地の生産者含めて酔った方の話を聞きました
すると皆さんなんとなく共通して言われていることがあるんです
自分たちよ私たちいいものを作ってしまう
じゃけどなかなかげない
体としてですかといややっぱり者だ駅行種
いやー櫂アイ
いいからさ
なんだこのあたり自分の立ち位置が合いそうなと思いました
まずは一つの相談にぷと絞って生涯ったアップしようと思います
じゃあ何の商材かと
いうところで言えば残念でもなかなかわからなかったんでそれで参加ての旅の中で
出会った商材をしつずつディスタッフをしていて
そのため何も仕事で行こうと思っ
えそのリストが約300アイテムぜ
うわぁ結構多いなと思いまして
じゃあドーンとして泥を絞っていくのがいいのかなぁと思っ
にやっぱり日本人に欠かせないものがいいなと思います
なおかつ消費者の館から見た時に大量生産されているものとそうじゃない
しっかりこだわって作っているものを無意識であって
家庭をピンとっ
うちの1つが将棋だったろう
て次はじゃあそういうのプラモとしたセラバーロウと思いまして
醤油の足袋屋町
今まで10年くらいかけて400円バル
直説法のプラモと思ってい
400という数そこそこのたちだと思うんですけれどもやはりそれだけ
方もすると何となくこう感知十分というのができ
結構皆さんとかも例えば4校とか言われて初めて行った土地で初めて入る飲食体
初めてなんですけど一歩その店内に入ったときに
あっ
なんか子供しれないかもしれん
もしくはちょっと失敗したかもしれないっていうなんで終わりかもしれないですけれど
も
いたようななんだか
私は省の蔵元ニッポン杯としょうゆの香りふわぁとこつつまれると同時にあっ
このプラモとすること楽器ありそうだ
っていう風になったちょっと休憩飲んでるなぁと
実際に作っている生産者の方に話を聞くとすごくこの人魅力的って感じる方
もしくはん
ねちょっとこのしたあんまり好きになれそう
例えば分かりましたそのちゃんにー者が何が違う
っていうのを考えていきたいというのがちょうどテープ
これが実際の勝利のた山本さんこういうところを知っ
そして一つの蔵元
いっぺんにある小麗さんなんですけれどもあの一瞬 f 4の4位浮上すぐ近く
ん
ベインは飲食店さん向けの醤油を作っているのでこの近所に住んでいる方も大きい証明
されるけど面白いところで代理のっていうのは庄司産だという
この小麗さんに若いフラフラした
エアの私のほぼ同世代の私が本した時社長さんが何か違いそうだなんていうことで
同生協させてくれてお話をしたんです
そもそもなんで開いたの
動画松よし com 保健師すごく感動した
ああそうそういうものって言うとその場にもともと
あのー大手の企業に勤めていて
止めて書いてある家で幌してそう一部も会第望楼しているとやっぱり日本すごくいい
なあという思いがあって帰って来て地元に昔ながらのおっちな上で仕組みを知る章良さ
を見てや
ブログ担当したんですって言うんです
ただいざ申請のプラモとに入ったはいいけれども
何をしていちょっと舌わからないんですよでしょうね
だけどさっきの受け活動するって各紙とも同じ形がじゃないですかみたいな話をして
いただく
じゃーん
フラ見学のツアーをしようと思っていう
最後の位浮上がする近くなって単語言を左右
たくさんいるんですけど細々と倶楽部楽ライブの中に作ってはグラムだったのでこのお
客さんをプラの中逃げて実際に ok を診てもらおうと思います
ということをやり始めますか
この後の話は後日談ですけれど
その彼がそんなことをしよう
いうと音もといった蔵人さんたち大阪大
ます
小退けていメーター take 2メーターぐらいのくさがって3000リットルとか
4000 l はい6
例えばそこに見ず知らずを第三者が入って例えばタバコの一本でも中に入れちゃったら
を存在としては数百9の形
しそもそもこの勝利作るは2年3年かけて作っているのを誰が責任取るんですが社長と
話した
操車所がまだだけど若い子が言うな1回やしてみよう
ということでスタートしたそうです
近くのホテルサント家にビラとかを待っと結構多くの方が家てくれたそう
中には若くて綺麗な女性の方もたくさん
職人の立場からすると薄暗いところでもともとと毎日作っている誰かに分かったて
きれいな女性が入ってきてわーいキャップです
その代わり指摘
じゃあちょっとダメてみる帰って思考じゃないですか
僕美味しいってもチェーンって結構入ってくれるのに
職人さんすっかり張翼者しまったみたいで今じゃですね地味ですか
社長歳爆この辺が一番大きかったっています
それに社長さんがすっかり今日よくてしまって今だと学生のインターン生を定期的に
受け入れるようになっちゃう
私がそのクラブとに行くたびに違う
若い男の子女の子が右往左往しながら
の仕事をして
押されたこの辺なくて外からいくら
プラ幻神あったらいいです良いですよって言ってもおそらく実現できなかったじゃない
かなと
高には大人間が入って言ってちょっと書きますだからこそできた辺が立ち上げた
その勝利の業界てー
横どうした
高いない
ただこれも考えれば当たり前のことでお供と醤油ってその土地で作ってその土地の人に
販売していたので旅行同士の松屋さんっていうのを超がつくだいぶルカ
なので地域の神ありとかで顔を合わせるけれども
じゃあお互いの製造現場に入っていって中を見たことがあるかというと
いやありませんとかたこと
何か製造で困ったことがあったらどうするんですか
っていうのもなかなか専門的な相談できない大きな行前だっています
私がある醤油の蔵元に行った時に若手の食
30日
方向を卒業してもずっと処理作りをしているので30代といつも人生の半分章作ってい
ますいるような職人じゃったんです
ほっともっといいショーを作りたいです
ほんと科学磯で勉強しているけれども
あっ違うキャスんですけど
だったらちょっと違いそうな処分者紹介するよということですごく離れた地域の同世代
の職員さんを紹介して
ふたりが電話でやり取りをし始めるとすごくを盛り上がってくれて
こっちも彼のところがじゃぽんとしょうゆの仕込みをする時に決断に来てをって話
だぜひよねそういう計画が実現しそうだったんですけれども
こちらの社長されたすごく心配をして僕に電話を書いているということ
何かというと本土を仕込みにいたせてもらうことになったという話を聞いたけれども
そういって先方さんに大雪すごく失礼なこと
選んだ音でしかというと
しょうゆの仕込みといえばその松屋の神髄ともにいる企業秘密だとボタンを持っている
言ってみればその蔵元が2重ね2100年積み重ねてきた
ほんとその部分を抱い倍の超イヤに見せるなって私の感覚からは言えないと思う
ただ安い大丈夫ですよいう話をして売りぶりにじゃあいいよということでいることが
できたんですけれど
下にいたら入ったで
202カレンいた
けどもずっと海の家に泊まり込みで24時間8純正がずっと一緒だったってです
ずっと消費話だっ
それがすごく良かった
実際どうだったという話を聞くと確かに企業秘密しちゃっていけないとくっていうのが
あると思う
ただよくよく考えてみるとその部分ですー
小さいと
それよりも本当にできることををすればそれ以上のものが帰って来なっていう実感が
あるのです
は困ったな作業ですけれども蔵が違うと作業の手順が違ったりとかで
なんでこんな言い方をするんですか
なんでこんな現象になるんですかっていうのほうですかしちゃっていきたいとおもい
ます
部分宴会だったんだよ
これも若い世代の職員と少し昔の職人さんとの感覚の違いということもいえるんじゃ
ないと思います
よく地域づくりに必要な要素としては買い物と予想ものと赤ものの3者が必要だよっ
要はすべてを人なんだよという風に捉えることも出来るかもしれないですけれども
私はこの中で若者っていうするとこ
と冒頭に少しお話しさせていただいた
私が初めて行ったプラムというを入ったところすごく魅力を感じる
要素として可能かつ共通してるのって若い子さん方がいるということ
なおか2は改札の方がイキイキ働いている
倉本ってプラ全体の魅力がすごく合うのって感じ
でこの業界が
もっともっと魅力的になるためにはある
沢山のまたものが入ってきてくれて
高尾5着ちゃんと勝ち馬せてくれる
それがきっかけとなって業界全体がなもっともっと魅力的になってくれたらいいなと
一緒にさを考えてい
ありがとうございます
[拍手]